good
but now i can't see anything
somebody sent me a message
we are good
[Music]
oh thank you i do appreciate that let me
get that back
what the hell is
oh my girl is on
take time
all right you sit there you get like 40
different tick tocks
that's it
yeah rip
that pushes you bro
[Music]
i broke his arm i'm trying to break them
oh you're not
get back in that bubble
oh the bubble disappeared
you got to put on that blue gear if you
see it
yeah it drops if you if you see it on
the floor it's not poo pod stuff
remember we started all over
yeah
switch my heavy up now you're flipping
[ __ ] for the flipper baby
yeah hit you in the stomach with a
little bit off yeah
switching it up
this thing will be art since you won't
be barked
boy don't you do those bad moves on me
boom hit you in the stomach
i make it hurt
ah
who's
that king
baby
there we go
hey
hey breaking [ __ ] [ __ ]
get out the sky oh god i said hi
hey come here man you got that little
light on your head boy come on man
looking kind of weird
take that shield off you
come here
watch out man
you need some spunk on the floor nasty
little things
i want to sound like a boss right there
boy
riff on me
somebody texting me
it
i told you man you gotta watch out man
oh you did
[Music]
no no no
no
no no no no no no not like this not like
this
[Music]
that's your riff
hold on let me grab i'm gonna switch it
up hold on hold on
since um i'm gonna do stasis
and i got
i got arc stuff so
it definitely messed it up over here
um you know what
now i'm gonna use this heavy right here
for that
ah
hey yo
hey guys gotta jump for my next meeting
enjoy it
catch you guys later
i put that
on everything
i
[Music]
watch out now
hey i remember this
trying to see this last time huh
i like the t-phone loose
this is what i do
just for you
tag team back again
they still bought it
oh hey that's when you put the
all my stuff full
oh i gotta get you out man
i
get away from addict
boy
deadly disciples
okay
they're right on your mix
we got girl
where you are
you want to rough with the big boys
hey
take that off hey girl come on come on
come on that's a damn it's a death a hit
different a bit different it's different
it's real different man
shining in the light
oh they gave me a new weapon hold on let
me try this one out there for size man
oh no that's uh
oh no man hey i gotta upgrade this one
hey man everyone in the chat can you
everyone everyone fight can you hear
[Music]
oh i need some money
you felt like going broke
yeah i got it it's right here man
oh
hold on
yeah that's it yeah i got to change that
stuff up
ah
i want to run with the big boy
what's that uh dude hey you bout to get
nasty all right how does that sound does
that sound better can you guys hear me
better now
and uh i know the camera's not on i will
be turning it on momentum i shouldn't be
able to use the light again well what's
your caller
the traveling would never
oh
yes this is
i'm gonna put a bubble right
here
right on this
stuff looking kind of different
take that off
take off your clothes
it's in the stomach and let it go
pause
huh
in there i'm picking up unusual energy
readings from that statue
let's make a quick detour
i don't know
how we should make a quick detail maybe
we need to make a quick detail
brother
shoot them guardian
okay
shoot them off
i'm off man what is the
software is going to happen
carry gonna happen so i don't play this
game and you guys know that you being
messy on purpose
thank you
because i'm just running from
oh here we go
no
it doesn't look hive
i've never seen anything like it
waste
baby
what the hell just happened my control
is disconnected hey stop it
thank you
i knocked the battery out
yes you can do that on the xbox
controller because you can change
yes this is the campaign for the queen
no we playing the old stuff
yeah that is kind of a stupid question
i get it but he probably don't play that
game
he's a match looks amazing what is this
it's the newest freshest part where do i
download it take my money
shot them in the services
good boy
oh
somebody hit me with something in the
back of the head
actually let me just go ahead and put
that tweet out saying attic
oh
god
in time
stay back in here stay back in here hold
on back
where the other boy come on far out
they're not on the ps5 you should know
that
you know damn well me ps5 god do this
yes it can king
that is freaking out after horizon
that king's so messy oh he jumped off
the roof
support
just died
there are reports of savathun trying to
capture void light from dead guardians
maybe this is related
maybe she's been stunning the void all
this time
here
check everything
i checked everything
[Music]
i like the way this place looks
yeah it looks like membrane
i died on the floor
blood blocker
it looks like a hive [ __ ] man where it's
almost about destiny
you guys are so messy
oh seventh dude that was sabbath hurry
you so hard i didn't see her
she wouldn't want to be fast
they want to be fasting first
oh something else coming out of there
though and they locked it the hell away
from the attic they lost it
he's on you
come on buddy
did not know if we don't want to run
with you wanna rock with me
oh he put up his shield
like he's nice like that hey buddy
unfortunately for him the shield only
works one way
oh god
i was born in it he just he's
i was born in the life
no
oh he just revived himself
i can't believe it
there's no other way
[Laughter]
we have to keep going
hey
mix it up
that's it now rap flag come on
rally up
oh you started it yeah
[Music]
thank you for showcasing this amazing
sony shooter
i don't care who first who laughs baby
but you know what you know what
dos this is community shooting this is a
solo shoot this is an exclusive shooting
everybody can have part of this shoe
i love it i love it
i love it that's for the streets
what the hell happened
hold on
buy an accolade because i ran out of
ammo and for some reason i thought i
could maybelline today
where's the worldwide gym skin at
that's all we need
that's all we need the worldwide gym
skin
the j
i the m
the white
oh my god
attributes collected
what i want to
hold on hold on hold on easy man
i got something i wanna put in
jim ryan playing witch queen to death i
don't know he made maybe
the g turtle
i got a witch in the back
acula
i'm in the dish pan
oh
that's what i've been killing people
[Music]
dead
we gotta do it again
oh yeah that's right you fade away i was
about to get you king i don't like how
they don't worry about it
all right now i can actually
let me see about switching something up
here
all right
are you gonna feel the wrath of that
king
oh man i jumped off the damn man
so
where's
all right
remember we got a full back
now watch out for the
the moss
appreciate it john
gone for it try to keep
watch out
dude hard i think i'm going to sleep to
the sleep uh switch to the sleeper
all right hold on let me switch my
weapons
all right before we started let me
search my wife okay
so i could turn on the camera
oh
yeah i got his nipples out man
everything was out oh man
there we go
i should use my no compulsion for
freezing front or feeding frenzy
grips
oh they changed the joint around
on a void
pocket singularity finds possible
be devoid
child of the gods
okay you guys
hold on
let me make sure the camera look good
how do i look guys
how do i look
shirt question man you better say i look
fantastic
pause it's a trick question
nova walk
on
vortex cataclysm
actually
all right hold on switch up
the nasty oh
there we go now i got the beanie on hold
on here you go
oh double lock baby we both paid for it
man we both paid for it
oh man let's get it
what
all right let's let's play very passive
this time
well now i'm playing fast
is that the tribute dude
how are you doing back here what is this
thing
oh they changed how i do my job
oh man
i think i'm giving up on void buddy
try to get that dude before that shield
comes back
this year
it's not happening
i made a
calculated error
calculator
all right delivery of the tribute
this is no i'm not doing this i don't
know go go up there king and uh
get ready to grab this the moment i kill
the witch
oh my god i'm just too shocked
buddy
oh
melt him
yeah yeah
i got melted
he's melted it's on the steps
if you pick it up you can win
oh and
for the woman i think
i did
put your hands in the air for a dick
palms in my hair like you don't like
hair
i'm not going in there hold on hold on
hold on hold on
all right i got a sniper rifle that i
don't care about
oh yes god yes you
yes you get off of me a sleeper get off
of me
put this here
oh yes oh god you are you're a godsend
come on
excuse me
infusion yes infusion
66 yes yes fusion yes
come on come on come on come on
stand up
yes
put these bonds on atl he's in line to
get a ps5 hopefully he'll get one god
bless man
that's what you looking for get that
god bless
oh my character look at it look at
i can't help that i got this gear on me
i got blue stuff on it i was looking
nice yesterday
let me see
yeah but now i'm a blue baby yeah blue
baby you see me a blue
hold on
let me put down this gold men's money
man because i don't have no money
let it rain upon me
got everything we need
yes
rock him to sleep with the ball you
ready
yeah
using that boy no more void is dead for
the
warlock mess it up
cut scene
don't skip it
i wasn't going to but now
oh that seemed like a playstation delay
this doesn't look like a hive you don't
got quick resume no what is this
someone said this is the third person
they played
so far away from the tv to feel like
third person
is there any particular reason it has to
be third person
like playstation games
i got an aspect
oh my
these nights i got aspects
it's good night crawlers podcast
i like that name knight problem
aspects are equipped in your subclass
menu inspect your subclass by trusting
why
okay i did that now what you want me to
see
i don't care about it i mean i can
understand that
he said if you can customize your
character why does
um
third person should be an officer
oh
the thing is though is like the
mechanics of destiny doesn't work very
well third person
oh you can upgrade it oh they want you
to upgrade every goddamn
oh
okay
sorry
buddy
what if you could just open that door
it was worth a try
someone called and said eric would you
put your when you put your clothes on do
you look at yourself in third person
be nice chad
that was pretty funny though
stop mothering attic
something's frozen at the bottom of my
screen talking about the aspect of
oh no problem man i like this
is that everybody yep
garden
it's her
how did you do it
how did you fight straight to destroy
something so like yourself
hold on hold on hold on don't go yet
i gotta figure out why this thing is
doing this to me
aspects are equipped in your subclass
menu inspect your active subclass by
pressing y
did so
or you can upgrade this
i don't care about none of this stuff
there
to look in a
what is she doing down there
she's making more
okay i'm killing friends
you just leave
yeah
what's with these gods just like being
scared of us and leaving
dog they're not scared
we're just not worthy at any time until
we pay for it
[Music]
oh my god
ah
all right i'm putting everything into
the sleeper
rip in the back with orbeez
something's transpiring that's up
oh what the hell
throw an oval bomb buddy
i didn't realize she had the light too
that scared me
i'm gonna get on the other side
i'm not trying to get hit by another
at least i know long lasting
trying to hit her with the sleeper
and the witch queen is over expansion's
done that's all folks
it didn't seem too easy
ah
back up
[Laughter]
she got us told she wanted to steal our
ghost
[Applause]
chapter one investigates the
reappearance of mars mysterious
ghosts
which queen pretty good man which queen
pretty good
uh people that are checking hdr is wrong
i blame sony
people that are in here
no that's not that was i was
exaggerating firebird that's not the
whole dlc people thought i was being
serious
wow
guardian
guardian do you read me
we're here aikora we're back on mars
back
from where
sabbath is throne world
i know we should have checked in but we
had sabathune in our sights that might
have been our only shot at her we
couldn't miss it
i understand completely
that's not like savathun to allow
herself to be seen so easily
it's because she's not scared anymore
something else
before we left the ship we ran into one
of our nights
and
it had a ghost aikora
same as any other light bearer
a ghost
a hive knight with a ghost
but that means
sabbath stole the light
but that's impossible
isn't it
impossible
with sabathune nothing is impossible
17 was hiding this whole time but the
moment she felt like she had something
over here she like now you got to get up
out of here
the witch queen
hive god of cunning and lies
hive legend tells us she was born on a
hostile far-off planet hell would there
be she would have lived a short
uneventful
where the ancient worm gods offered them
for untold ages
they devoured life and light wherever it
could be found facing little resistance
until they tried to take on the
guardians
after the death of her brother oryx
savathun went into hiding
not out of fear of course
but out of strategy
because savathu knows the best way to
beat your enemy
is to join
them in her greatest trick yet
she infiltrated the vanguard weakening
us from within
and stealing our most sacred resource
the one thing we thought she could never
touch
the light
lord cognito's favorite osiris
was a rat he was taking
[Laughter]
ato
playstation
now be five when you install horizon
forbidden west
what you need to do though man is like
use your legs when you pick up that
thing because it's going to throw your
back out
that's something totally different but
what i definitely would tell you is
what you have acquired your first
fragment quickly
they keep bothering me about my subclass
and telling me a quick fragments
that i don't see
so
chess piece
i don't think that's
why is it bothering me so much girl
not helping did this dude do this to you
with your sub class and all that other
stuff
no
oh
yeah it can't bother me i had to do it
like three times before it would shut up
oh i finally went away
i gotta go to where's the vault terminal
good i gotta put all these weapons that
i do have
inside the vault
all right guys you're gonna
see me pop exotics right now to see if i
can get the new exhaust
all right so let's sign into xbox
on a website
go to seasons
past seasons
current season
rewards
collection
okay let's go to rewards
yeah
where's my two exotics they took my two
exotics
and grams that i had in there
would you have them
wow in my vault
i mean um in my post office box
wow
oh yeah i had a
i had two exotics in me
all right hold up
do you profile i'm trying to remember oh
she's in progress
all right there we go
she chosen verizon
previous season
claim
doom project so nothing that i need
claim
lying
okay
so nothing
absolutely nothing unfortunately
they didn't even really go into detail
how mars came back showed a cutscene
tomorrow's coming back
you know what's funny
bearing hive
just another example of them giving us
old content repackaged as a new toy
yep
wasn't we at mars when we gonna go to
pluto's between are becoming
increasingly blunt
especially between what's right and
what's wrong if i had been in your place
to be honest i don't know what i would
have done
but there's no use dwelling on that
let's assess what we do know
i see you picked up a clue along the way
one that might explain why savathun
decided to return alongside mars
according to your ghost telemetry that
fragment is giving off the same
vibrations as the pyramid tech relic
that just so happened to return with
mars
go take a look i'll explain more when
you report back
where's all the stuff that i get when i
buy this crap
where's the kryptonite
um
your crypts are
your kryptonite
do you know cryptart
does anybody know a crypto
put us in the sub basement
guardians have been coming since it
reappeared
no way they'd have missed this
it's definitely new
let's get it closer
let's see
don't you love how the how
mars disappears comes back with new toys
it's like bungie didn't want to explain
what happened
what was the raid that we had on mars
before
oryx right
now
oh yeah
chat
i don't think we've ever had a rage
you know it was a complete waste of time
but tight
[Laughter]
didn't do anything with that that planet
the entire time that destiny was around
didn't do anything with that planet
we're gonna get it again
sorry y'all i can't eat regular chips i
gotta eat these vegan chips that's extra
loud
you're not sorry
this is true i care not
create a new weapon modify an existing
one
protective glaze
empty shaft sockets
low impedance
increase range duration decrease shield
i want to shield
this weapons greatly increased magazine
side yeah let's do that
who i like i like this
anti-momento socket i don't even know
what that is
we're shaping the weapon king
finalize the shape
ass
weapon shaped
oh it's it's a it's an energy weapon
yeah and you get to toss it and you get
to
work around with it
i'm going outside where i can play with
it
i want to play get this um
reshaping extraction
you got the bounty over there
no i don't think there's any
uh areas in the game where we could go
get this bounty over here first
and yeah go talk to that quarter
speaker and
enclave okay
now keep in mind guys i'm only going to
be streaming youtube one time
for this expansion
uh after youtube we will be streaming on
twitter
making breakthroughs left and right
so
the relic rendered a full blueprint out
of a single fragment
almost as if you were shaping that
weapon based on its own memory
which parallels the distortions all over
the planet
open wounds where the past bleeds into
the present
somehow the relic can manipulate time
with the right kind of it of course
what savageone happened to have
but could she use the relic
and what for
the questions just keep piling up
it seems the answers are buried within
savathun's throne world
i need someone to go in and dig them up
guardian
how do you feel
working
with the hidden
alliance aligned with the center plain
capable of dispelling light
stay strong titanic
anti-barrier scout overload rounds
unstoppable hand cannon
barrier champions
pulse rifle so i'm gonna go with uh
oh
barrier i'll go
i'm gonna stop a little anti-barrier
i'll go anti-barrier
wow
here's a campaign i'm pretty sure
you have uh six uh nodes for your um
what you're calling right for your
artifact right yeah yeah
what's six no i love absolutely
guess when you give all of them
at the destiny 2 the witch queen brought
to you all by playstation
all yeah let me make that announcement
on twitter real quick
what an announcement
that i've not have been had
let's see
i said attention realm attic shows
cancer today with lord addict and hustle
maybe because he is sick and i showed
the gift as the witch
i would have did it if it was like maybe
i won't cancel this week i'll just send
i'll just delay it to the mom
omega strike
what is the mega strike
land hits with this sled launcher to
load missiles
long press and then fire to launch all
missiles
classic campaign legendary campaign
all right we gotta hit this poll right
here
a second the crypto and everything is
inside what the hell
i don't think there's a cryptocurrency
evidence walls here
this is the post box the vault
i don't think it was a kryptonite
who's going to just defuse my damn
whatchamacallit this is good yes you
going to the tower
you wanna go to town
i don't need to
i do i got a whole bunch of stuff
seven things
let's see what the rats what everybody
doing
let me see where everybody playing from
sinister on
damn
we are xbox dominant podcast i mean i'm
screaming
got me uh
you're playing by yourself well yeah
he was in the chat a minute ago
he probably started
scream if you're still in the chat
join our party
let me call forte and see if he's close
to being but
i mean we're not really struggling by
ourselves but it would be nice to have a
third
nope damn showing struggling
where are you at
if you ain't on destiny what you really
doing forte
eris says throne words are kingdoms of
thought
in the first
desire he's no he's
just started the first mission we will
have to
what's strange to me is that she's
vulnerable i'm joking
why would she just let us walk in
oh she stole the light
hey grace uh
block that person that's doing all that
oh god oh well this is the machine gun
check the season pass
don't delete the message grace just
click on their name and click um
click
uh
hide user from account
what's up
i can barely
yeah i mean
if you don't care too we could probably
get through this [ __ ] real real fast
yeah i don't know i don't care
what i'm doing
oh yeah
we're just like two or three
we finish
what you're doing
right now
yeah we finished that already
yeah the play just kind of uh
but you got to consider two this is just
a legendary clay too
uh you don't have a lot of the the
upgrades that is optional
okay maybe maybe
okay the clay's a little bit better now
you can like fall off the attack
let's go ahead and join him
yeah once he sends the invite we just
want him yeah
i really like this
oh
no
are you playing on legend because we
only played only
yeah that's all i'm playing on okay
is that it did the forte play online
come on i played on legends it's all i'm
playing on this legend
let's give the maddest credit man
i was playing sick of truth the one
obsidian made
i got to play it i'm never played any of
them
i want to get the thing
the thing that you can put on your nose
this doesn't smell apart
now i was um
playing um
the game that just came out cyberpunk
the glaive is pretty cool uh before time
is it
yeah you'll get it in like two missions
i like how you could pick the perks i
love that
yeah that's cool
i like if you go to your um
the season pass
wonderful things there
it is some
what the hell is this
that's a machine gun
seems like a fusion rifle
oh yeah you talk about the yeah
oh there's an issue with the glaive if
you have the glave on you can't uh
shoulder charge
i don't know if that's intentional or
white addict's ship is a meteor yeah i
grinded a law a lot for that damn meter
media
that was sabotage hurry oh you can shoot
her
yeah you can
i just found out some stuff that i can
do
and i didn't learn the first time they
should find out some stuff too
yeah we're not too far behind
this [ __ ]
what's up fam
okay okay glad you can't take on a
nightmare with powers
i'm gonna write that in my uh
oh he put up a shield
no that's impossible
is that
a ghost
well i'm bad at it
get me closer
oh
it shoots like a fusion rifle but if you
hold it it starts shooting like a
machine gun
yep
that thing is not like me
you see that right
oh oh that felt nice
oh my god i had to get rid of get rid of
that believe this
there's only one room we have for
annoying guardians and that room has
been
what has she done to you
i thought we killed kate
i didn't even get the flag
oh no no no no
we have an extra person now though
all they do and you know what destiny
does is just scale it up
but we could still regardless if they
scale it up we could still do
more damage to one person
you are right
that's what i needed to use
ftw on anything else
oh
i don't have any ammo because
there's a way
oh
you said up there like where's up there
and be careful we can't die a lot
there's gonna be a ogre that spawns
get ready yo you gotta be prepared for
that ogre
grab that you get to the middle and it's
over
we're getting more stuff at it
[Music]
there's a lot of [ __ ] there's a lot of
[ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] pop out of these chests
we ain't get no chest
no
oh [ __ ] i got a new left man
they're like you guys already did those
chests
we don't double reward people
we buzzy give me your money
that would be funny if you beat them
king and it's like swipe your car to get
these chests again
to get this chest
two strange coins thirty nine fifty you
can get these chests again you just
gotta pay the the low price of 199
gotta pay the fee it doesn't look like a
hive thrown world it's coming
yeah
he got attacked
he's attached to you
he doesn't respect
the knights
because he doesn't like the fact that
they got lights
they got my life that's the the jacked
up part they have my life
that dude keeps blasting off with that
damn cannon off
so forte does it look washed out for you
talk about this part
yeah a little bit
all right i thought it was just me
sorry must be a problem with the hdr
yeah it looks yeah it looks
yeah it doesn't look as bright as what
we just came from
yeah
i think the game overall in general
has this weird pastel color feel to it
yeah i have to look when we get out of
here i mean i i
voice was likely about to eat you up
they said those little dudes do
change my gauntlet
it's her
how did you do it
how did you find the strength to destroy
something so like yourself very easy
though
very easy
um i don't know what you mean uh
big grizzle
i don't know what you mean by like that
amount of armor you have to be a little
more
uh transparent what you mean by that
it's talking about all that stuff that
you got there man
you know when you go to when they go to
look they go to see your stuff man
tell them you'll be grinding them man
yeah that's yours
if that's what you're referring to
like kevin gates he don't sleep he don't
get tired
tell him about it
i was born into the light
you merely adopted it
i didn't see the light of day until i
was already
a small guardian
hey where you going man to look in the
mirror
and tell you what looks like these dudes
gonna be rallying flags and stuff out
here i was going to rally calm down
you too busy looking to see what she's
doing
you know
what big ass [ __ ] moth
she's gone boss man prophet
is it me or does your supers just feel
like
minor distractions
you're stealing you're not paying the
price
hey she helps you out man she out man
give me the business
addict oh man
i'm turning you guys up so you're louder
and in the chat than the game chat
you get me up forte you got 15 seconds
oh [ __ ] yeah you're like [ __ ] fake
night he realized that
five
followers
the king
if king wouldn't have been there for us
man it would have been a wrap oh they
blew up my stomach muscles
that's what happens the light is gone i
take the light with me
damn
all right
be careful now
she can't hold don't run out there get
your own kill
what why can't rally the flag what the
hell
oh buddy i didn't even get to rally
y'all thirsty man
that wasn't me
it was you
my bubbles up for 199 you guys take
refuge
darcy
don't take darcy i i stopped taking that
wow
said come and play with three people he
said
it'd be easy he said
got him up
hell yeah
that's my primary job
oh they're gonna kill me here
they're everywhere
you gotta fix that man
where did you get all that armor from
you know the glaze is a defensive weapon
as well
hold it
please
left man
here you can hide behind this
i saw that and it was like guess what
that's a discount that's only 30 cents
to my venmo
watch out now
they explode your hair
come on you're strong
that was too easy oh it's a chest no
it's not
people say you sound like you're dying
he said he don't care but she's alive
[Music]
i'm still disappointed man i'm still
very disappointed
capcom has been accused of adapting an
80 stock image for street fighter 6 logo
yeah
drama like damn
pack is looking kind of lean huh
and sometimes
damn hunter face down in the dirt
who didn't do that my
[Music]
back
from where
sabbath and strong world did my guardian
just sleep
because he didn't speak
that might have been our only [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] years
said something
wow i did not expect that to tweet me go
crazy like it did
a ghost
a hive knight with a ghost
but that means
sabbath stole the light
but that's impossible isn't it
impossible
with sabathune nothing is impossible
where my fire team at i do this by
myself why am i walking through this
desert by myself
what
people don't understand that porn wins
the war man
[Music]
that's it
where porn goes is where the winds are
sucks
the witch queen
hive god of cunning and lies
hive legend tells us she was born on a
hostile far right
where she would have lived a short
uneventful life
if it weren't for the worm familiar that
warned of an impending cataclysm
and so
she led her siblings into the depths
where the ancient worm gods offered them
immeasurable powers
whisperers
the high were born
and countless civilizations were
condemned to extinction
baron told ages
they devoured life
he might have been fined
if we paid that 9.99
after the death of her brother oryx
sabathune went i paid my giddy up bucks
not out of here
but out of strategy
because savathun knows the best
checklist
is to join them
you know first i want to shout out
people in the chat
that showed up to
my personal videos you guys have been
showing up there pretty hardcore and i
appreciate it and stealing our most
sacred resource
the one thing we thought she could never
touch
it's popcorn
yeah this [ __ ] ratchets up really crazy
yeah
got three people in there
because when there's one or two people
was able to i was able to take [ __ ]
knights down with
two
cannon bursts but now it's like i had to
reload and try to try it
try to relax a little on the custom man
just a little bit
what you say try to relax a little on
the cusp
are we straightening oh yeah
i'm sorry i didn't know that's fine man
it's fine it's cool you know i know we
streaming it's good man
you're a streamer you're streaming right
now i got you streaming i was just
streaming on twitch but people were
saying that they wanted it on youtube
too it says it's day one of which queen
i was all right we'll do it one time but
remember you guys you got in there right
now let's look he's a stranger
you know how sick
yeah tell me why it took away my two
exotic engrams
[Music]
yes sir did you call the post office
too exotics
it's like you got the season pass shut
up
you getting exotics in there now stay
there
chapter one
blows extended duration of your
overshoot you gain an additional shield
throw while in sentinel shield okay
hit a target with the avoidability or
valid explosion makes the
cause of them to explode oh i like that
oh
bionic speaker rules
yep let's get that
let's get my discipline up a little bit
oh
dig site
secret light universal ornaments
how about i say no
people are laughing about my post on
twitter
i said attention around addicts shows
cancer today with lord addict and hustle
and motive because he is quote sick that
i have a picture of the witch queen
oh lord
no man what what i i probably won't
cancel the attitude will probably be
tomorrow
i don't know it just depends on how it
depends how long it takes to get like
the the destiny is out of my system it
might be next month i don't know we'll
have to see like
you know what i might never do the attic
show again destiny might take my whole
life
oh my
homespun boobs
wallop ornaments
for what the boots of the assembler
haven't acquired that yet
or have to start back from the beginning
i don't know that's a call question
he said what you start for which way
you start from which
you can start from right now
one of you will let you pay your way to
the top
oh we're going back to the forge
forged by literally where being king was
so we weren't that bad
ahead of you
my biggest question is do you guys want
me to live stream
um eldon ring to youtube because i my
thinking is i've been trying to like all
the big big games do one the very first
stream
on the youtube channel with it you know
what i'm saying and then everything
after that you gotta go to twitch for
elgin ring is a big game though i don't
know if i want to stream that you guys
going to see me struggle i don't know if
i like that
i like this struggle oh
oh got the artifact it looks like oh
yeah
oh
adaptive glaze
that's cool othello
i can kill that
oh you could put
pick the mod you want
listen good thing about destiny this
time around is they're gonna make it
pretty easy
to
to get raid ready because if you finish
the campaign on legend you get like a
pair of like i think it's like 15 10 or
20 gear off the start so
i don't like twitch so many ads i i
respect that
i wish that if you had like prime they
would they would kind of do something
like youtube does where you don't have
to see ads but i think uh you know
twitch is a little bit different uh they
make money primarily through ads youtube
does i mean
amazon does so i don't see them ever
doing something like that
but it is i would rather see
i don't know like
uh hula because there for a while i had
the
uh
the the advertising hula
and i stopped that because it was
annoying but i liked on hula because
they give you the option on hula to see
all of the ads at once
so you don't have to see them throughout
the show
like some episodes do that not all
look at atl try
asking my girl she got a twitter i see
you atl
she got a twitter it's called nanya i
actually don't know if she has twitter
oh
yourself around the corner i'll catch
you following my wife
oh it goes down even more
possible
oh you can do these
you don't hear things just saying that a
minute ago
wait
and then i found out something because
you're gonna do something i did too
hold up
do it you saw that right
bye
[Laughter]
i did the same thing
did you enjoy yourself
i did you have a nice fall it was fun i
enjoyed it man
there's nothing there of of a
significant so let's go
nothing
at all
come talk taikora after you do that
other thing over there so we can go man
yeah
she's gonna give me the artifact not
brown
let me check my my colors man
cuz my everything looked fine on my
dashboard and everything it's just this
damn game man
let's see
oh it's probably inside the game so
let me sit right here
video
128 hurts
oh why is my field of view at 105. oh
cause they don't got 120. hmm
that's crazy
oh let me put motion blur on
yeah oh film grain is on
maybe if i take phil gray
i was trying to find uh someone to play
uh destiny with
uh i was sitting there and
call uh because cogwar is working
obviously and sinister and them already
teamed up with someone and i'm sitting
there looking i'm like i'm about to do
this whole damn thing on on legend by my
day himself
and i'm sitting here and the king jumps
i'm like king i gotta get him before
someone else starts
he don't know
he don't know i was at bj's and chris
called me
and i see a number from texas
like where you like my
i'm walking in dj's i got locked out my
car today so i had to wait for um triple
a to show up
so it put me back a half an hour
normally i'd have been home at 12
actually i have to give it to bungie
the release of this was flawless i
didn't have no issues no
no no issues like none
that's
like we can't act like that's the
statement
not the standard but
everybody was thinking this was to be
like a [ __ ] show today
i said i don't know what level in the
queue i'm going to be probably like 3
000 or something now
and i don't know what they did
yeah i just logged in and there was no
queue
nothing
let me blew my mind
let me put do not disturb
and everybody is on
everybody is on right now you guys want
to see how big the iop clan is on uh
on destiny
don't be putting out people government
like that
it's a gator tag so if they if they
shame do they gamer ties you know that
is a lot of people
all these people and i almost had to do
this stuff by myself built according to
safe desires of the creator
but now we got forte in here
king david
everything here is in you
what's strange to me is that she's
vulnerable here god wouldn't let you do
it by yourself
so let king lock himself out of his damn
car
never did that
last time i did that
i was delivering
pet food
got locked out the car
this random guy in the street came and
said i can get you back in
man these nights are
rougher than normal huh
[Music]
and then again it's probably me because
i'm so obsessed with using this new
blade too
i gotta get back to me using my same
weapons
why are they using these fire things
i got iron mike
says
yeah i'mma drop forbidden west for which
queen it's more of the same
[Music]
and people don't know the concept of
breaking
because actually
breaking is when you can't recover your
console
so if you have a hard reset that's
something totally different buddy
oh god i just realized
i saw this girl i guess she had a hard
reset console and lost all her info
i mean that sucks too but
i don't know i just don't think those
consoles are ready shout out to jason
ronald and the team
putting together a superior product
i just purchased another little man so
that's for
birthday purposes
yeah
i like the the xbox series s but i'm not
feeling that a lot of these games being
30. i get it that that's how it was
designed you know every game is going to
run exactly like the x but
it's definitely
yeah
i think the s is mainly designed for the
madden players the fortnight players the
warzone players like i think it's more
designed for that kind of demographic is
not necessarily people playing like a
variety of games every year
it's called the casuals
yeah it's a casual box
yeah like the ps4
let's follow the signal
foreign
can i just walk through this no
you have to use the glaze to get in
oh i gotta kill everybody
you know where i'm coming from you know
what i'm saying
i'll change my shirt do i get another
thank you sir may i have another
how did you do that
it's like you created those platforms
out of thin air oh
what's this
it's like tinctures of queens
ten seconds
huh
spooky as hell boy
yeah
oh too deep daddy
about the wall all the way down
what was that
up there i think that door will lead us
the way out
so she's basically loki
hmm i'm sensing more psychic energy
nearby
it might help us find our way out of
here
[Music]
[Music]
thanks
zelda mechanical
a lot of heart baby a lot of art
the 10k shirt is over man they're done
but we'll have a 15k shirt won't we king
yes sir
man y'all was selling 10k shirts at 12k
it was crazy
yeah it was an old four shirt stop okay
i'm not gonna be putting up with this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i still love your body
shirts and y'all [ __ ] y'all freaking
1500 over that number
oh it wasn't my fault i was told that
the game was done
legit
okay what do you what do you know about
business trust and verify right
yep
and you know what i trust and i didn't
verify
[Laughter]
you 100 right
yeah
i trusted
though never had an issue before
yeah god man these guys take so many
hits
wait till y'all see what's really going
on
hey got a five dollar super chat from
hero ava king are you telling me the ps4
can't hold on it's nuts
no i don't think so pognan
i think everything about old buddy is
kind of weak so just saying
i got it and actually i gotta call sony
today so they can let me into my account
that's the only reason why i haven't
been on my playstation because i got
two games that i did buy did you i
should have never trust them dude
and play them
one of the greatest games one of my
greatest games
last of us too
[Music]
these knights are really tanky
boy
oh y'all over there still fighting baby
oh where you at
i'm in the front
oh
i'm at the gate
no king is not on a ps4
i'm damn ps4
ah beat your mouth up with your fists
it sounds painful i'm day one i'm not
struggle bus dude
trying to figure it out i would like to
figure it out before they went into the
development i had mine
in the launch window well you know i
guess it wasn't the launch window
because
sony's launch was a little different
than my launch one
[Laughter]
it's a very long it's a very large
window
i have my day one buddy day one two
i had enough
to sell
and they were sold
oh man somebody put a bubble on that one
the signal
told you i have friends
we are friends we got to capture
something
over here over here
oh
stand on our hand oh respond restricted
oh i'm hiding here
rhinoview with the contact who's the
contact is it aaron
hey
make a run for it
on me
can you make sure they don't kill me
oh
here he comes
did he come here
close the door and say that would be 199
to the nearest paypal close to you
before i open the gate or a lost
guardian
the suzy cathy or paypal
all payments
[Music]
what are they doing here there you go
just gonna tether all that and direct it
who's who's who why is this scoring here
why are y'all there really to play
i already i just rallied
oh
[Music]
is a flag
oh
and they didn't even put me in your boat
another barrier over here next to me and
being
a barrier knight
a barrier guard
they're fighting this fight
he's got light it seems
foreign
primary
it would be a lot more nice if we had a
third person
bulls i had a giant ball too i killed
him
we didn't have any special for him so
that's why i did i had a giant ball you
want to see his body right here i
believe you i took out the one in the
middle with two yellow horns so
oh
yeah we could use your help a little bit
oh he's coming to us yeah it's time to
run
i'll put on that weatherhorn cut it out
act like you know
there you go
yeah i got a lightning blast
from the side oh we all got the job
yeah
just get your butt down here i don't
have a i don't have a reebok
you could pick if you don't know
no
they don't go anywhere without being
directed
so here we go here we go
upstairs
by myself
man you mad at this
uh
all right
in the middle
there's one more left one on the other
side is in the middle
[Music]
oh yeah he's right here
oh he's on my
he's running
all right everyone back to the entrance
another hype wielding the light eyes up
guardians
oh shoot
in the middle
all right there's one
oh snap
oh my god
get up here
where is he oh i see him
make it harder for those regular ass to
get it
i'm gonna focus on the um the width
roof in the back
[Music]
almost
focus on that
all right kill that witch i'll go grab
the uh
the ghost from
man she's strong
i will tell you to fall back until after
the killer
no if you kill her she's just gonna come
back to life
yes one of those things down there
healing her
i just think she's getting her health
back anyway
we have to do enough damage to the boat
kill let's do the man
oh this dude is so bad
so
oh
wow
let's just kill that night first that's
what i'm doing i'm just popping on him
all right
now
man i wish i had
don't get too close
she got two nights
oh my god
there's a nice on the side
got it
not sure i'll ever get used to seeing
ghosts serving the hive
all this was created after the collapse
the traveler released us just before it
went dormant
these ghosts had thousands of
opportunities to choose a guardian and
they passed right over humanity and
chose our enemy instead
i can't forgive that
better not forget it
never forget no retreat no surrender
oh what we got here we got a fusion
rifle
fusion rifle i like the way this one go
for those
impact crazy though
see what
what's this i got a 30 90
post
with an attorney
progress
you know what i haven't have i haven't
used my wrist driver but somebody gonna
get this work
who's gonna get anywhere
but put that work in there boy
let's check the clan see where everyone
is
1351
1387 1389
1384
1378 1374 1376
1376 1383
90
89 50 85
70.
we're sinister
1405 of course try hard
of course
oh we can use our ghost finally i mean
our
you
you brought us here
take it easy
just
let me explain it
what's he talking to
speak with the hive ghost
what is it what's going on
learn about the throne world
hard evidence mission accepted
okay
get what now deluxe edition upgrade two
dungeons and fires got this
i got all of it
everybody asking me to get something
they want you to to
to catch that there man
hey you know get awkward out of the way
first i always say
this uh pile of ash and bone used to be
my uh
yeah actually
don't worry about it
all you need to know
us wandering ghosts gave into the hive
believing we'd
found purpose and well peer pressure's a
hell of a thing
also because it's what the traveler must
have wanted then hive killed guardians
with light and you think
that's the traveler's world really
i'll tell you what i don't buy it not
anymore the witch queen's up to
something and you know maybe together we
get to
there's an old hive temple nearby with
sabotaging secrets inside that is all i
know what the why that's your game yeah
and when you get there radio me private
channels only
oh
almost forgot
the name's finch
honor to meet you yeah
for real for real for real real not just
real real
for real for real really real real
rank rewards and everything
what's up
see the clothes that he got there
so i gotta level up with this dude
[Music]
appreciate the uh
atl for the
for the share on twitter
why can't we pick up these reports
you'll see those reports there
it says you have to wait for the uh
so
you have to wait to finish the witch
queen campaign
or at least get further
it's a bumble cloud like
i think you can de-scramble this
the decryption codes in these oh it's
over there but i used to place you into
the hive
here's some secrets
the
the missions over here
tormenting young ghosts
let's ruin his day
i'm so sorry
over here
oh requires deep sight too
oh
[Music]
i gotta go
do some stuff after this one
all right
i'll be back on like a couple hours like
around seven
finch we're nearing the high
already
got you
who told me was going to pick yourself
up bro
yeah
i think you could have told me i didn't
know i didn't know i was looking at it
now we gotta get rid of that shrinker
oh
driving down
yolo
it's like you uh like you're doing the
kill
oh
wait
you mean that's the one yeah you know
what happened
came for her
back to the corner
clearly sabathune found her shell
impersonated osiris
but you're very eager to trust us
makes me uneasy hey hey
i am taking a huge chance trusting you
too you know
i bet you change your tune once you find
shakira
if we find her
then we can talk trust
it is it's it's a glaive it's a new
ability it's a new melee weapon and um
and
which
yeah i absolutely love it
[Music]
i can't
we're about to fight
oh cyrus
that's going to be yourself
what
that's what the dialogue said that
that's where we're going wow what the
hell
he threw a shield
whoa
damn man get hit by your own powers that
[ __ ] goes quick
that stuff goes real quick oh
hold on hold on
they really are being a little extra
with that
that flag which i don't mind but it is
funny
oh that's fine
that's called accessibility right there
bro
yeah that was about to die to that
not the data
oh it's one of the fire things
oh
he's coming up behind you
but you already took care of it
we got to get that knife
all right
all right let's go let's let's rotate
left let's rotate left
oh god we're getting hit hard
oh there's another one of those fire
things up there another yes one more
what are they even doing here
so
the chief oh
this is abomination right here
no
almost finished because 14 gotta go
boys
all right
out here i can get something inside this
gun i can change the aspect of it
to
okay
okay so that was just me so you can see
you can see
and i can't go to a tower i can't bust
my engrams open
i'm just stacking up engrams
dying within yourself
then yeah maybe
that's
some pretty blind judgment there my
name's good so far man
of suspicion
doesn't always mean you have multiple
options you know
i'm not saying buddying up with the hive
was right yeah yeah
it's interesting that ghost
you hanging out with weapons
to take down everything so we can keep
it
moving first leg
what the hell
no coco
daddy in the middle of killing
everything
left one
oh
i'm aiming for the back
his peoples in the back
yeah
come see cataract in the teams
dude
get out of here
oh my god
oh buddy
really
get back to roughness
so let's see your face boy
hold on hold on hold on hold on
i'm taking it with you
i don't know what the browser
oh
it's a whole brother spike up in here
remove him
the man is back
he's like get out
they're not playing
so to get this straight we're heading
into a dangerous temple i can't walk i
will say that
who is playing you're going to earn it
tonight
and they give you a choice too you can
play solved and this definitely is
interrogate me all you want but i am not
hiding anything i promise
honesty goes a long way with my
guardians cora ray
a leader of the vanguard
i signaled her just in case
let's call it insurance a watchful eye
in case your actions differ from your
words
wow it's uh yeah
i always wanted to work for the vanguard
with not four
do right by us and we can discuss a more
permanent role once savathun is dealt
with
yeah oh boy sound like man
i want to be part of you guys
you can't trust that dude at all man i'm
telling you right now
sit down man i heard about it
you like pookie
i don't know
not to be trusted
hit me right in the chest with a dirt
ball
yeah
this boy has dirt ball guns
go watch out man
you don't know who i am
that's my whole job
you can view weapon pattern progress
i don't care about all that
oh man
they're tethered too
what was me
oh man
hi daddy
yeah
that was unfortunate
all right
let's get rid of this abomination
oh
i fell through the floor
are you up to
you're looking so pretty what are you up
to i have spawns are so far away
of dudes up in the bushes man
they're just like
coming here
[Music]
using that driver
yes sir
it used to be something special you have
particle deconstruction
i got you
you can't handle grapes cocoa
breads are bad for dogs get out
get down
she was like yeah i got something where
i like my great
didn't like what we were doing
i like that even worse
they jumping me man
yeah i put that stuff over there
i was trying to save you from the
distance
[Music]
that's the last of them
let's head down
very
i'm the only one that survived
oh this is going to be disgusting
that was a giant score
was that a baron
i touched the wrong bubble
[Music]
oh my god
guardians out
what do we got to do
you gotta go all the way to the left and
the right where those emblems are in the
very back of the room there's a crystal
you have to break you can break that
crystal and give
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
oh two for one
all right let's go to the right first
that was a giant score you're gonna just
look just right all the way straight to
the back and then you gotta shoot
barons are supposed to wait
right here
all right
i gotta go to the other side
pistols out
all right
can you do damage to him yet
no
we have one more
there's one more
also there's three of them
oh no
that room was a little hectic
[Music]
a little
okay don't do anything yet
hold on hold on hold on don't you don't
don't
i'm infused i'm um getting better yeah
i'm infusing
yeah i'm infusing this gala horn
that's what i did
same thing you did
do you think i should um do a well
yeah do well just in case
i got a shotgun a scout rifle and a
rocket
what
oh
never mind my phone
all right that's it i ain't got nothing
else to go with the world hold on
let me hit the
where's the oh
my phone's right behind the green screen
i have to get it after this
all right so we're gonna go to the right
first yeah right first
yeah this way you can run that last one
it's going to be a little rough doing
that too
all right
right as one
what sword was i using i don't i wasn't
using a sword i use a blade
wow
oh
right
hold on hold on
yeah i gotta switch my battery hold on
hold on hold on yeah hold on
ah
that's a beautiful thing about an xbox
just change the battery
i don't have to tell myself to the world
are you guys ready
yeah ready yup watch out
let's stick together
which way we going
uh
so
still alive back there
there's no one rockets out here we go
all right
now we can uh
have adam and put my i'm gonna put my
super in the middle of the floor
oh what's that we gotta get to the
middle of it
i think that crystal in the middle
all right right here on me
oh that was it
it's taunting us
before we drop down there man
about all this stuff that i can level up
hold on king was about to pop it like
it's hot
boy you have no idea boy i'm about to
make it reckless
uh let me see
the backup mag in there
level that out real quick
um nothing ain't got nothing man i got
some boots
yeah 89 boots there we go
got some gloves
there we go
we got a helmet on that
uh what did you do kogo
you did something
you up to no good you got the no good
face you ready
i was about to go in on old buddy
you pop my super at home i super like a
g
yep i'm
ready let's go
the scorn are supposed to be mindless
but these
they're powerful
organized
if they act it's because someone's
telling them to what is going on in
destiny right now
the cabal the swarm perhaps he was
driven from the tangled shores yeah he's
smarter than we thought
i don't think it's him and you know this
house
then we don't yet know what we're
dealing with here
for now keep focused on the task at hand
guardian
oh gosh all right what time is it 4 45
ain't no time for you to go outside
you gotta do doodle
you ain't crying
oh [ __ ] so you're still alive let's go
music man let's go
rip on me
so
oh
tears up
bubble on me
you're taking me down the hallway
cuz i got a galley and know how to use
it
all right we got to go through these
things again
right side first
all right
let's go
all right
[Music]
oh you smash me right then back my head
boy
uh
all right watch it as we come out
pull them in draw them out move to the
top go to the left
follow addict
yeah
i'll go the other side
i'ma turn on the lights
oh
all the way across
so
so
oh the lights went off
yeah i'm getting out of there
[Music]
all right we gotta do it again
back on me
go right right where y'all at go right
in there where y'all at
all right
watch it
oh man
i got you i got you we got we got split
up there with that one
following right behind you
oh my god man this is this is getting my
my journaling on
huh
all right last one is all the way across
to the right
he's at the door the door watch it
[Music]
no man my hands are sweaty that was
well just it's just that one part where
we just messed up
yeah we're good let's go
left side first
uh
yeah left side first all right let's go
do we have to hurt them first
yeah oh yeah yeah we had to um let's do
damage first
oh there was a chieftain out there i
think
all right there it is
damascus
thinking it was it already
that's the first time he's ever ran in
the room with us like that
[Music]
take care of the dude out here first
him in his label mate
he's behind him
wow
he's just he's so strong if he hits you
one time
right left right
yeah but we gotta get we gotta take out
the first state first the first chief
rock it out
jeez dude
we got
[Laughter]
kill me
he said now i'll reveal my real form
my turn
okay
let's get on the other side
man what
all right guys
he's down the hallway harassing me boy
[Music]
here he comes
yo
how he dude is so perfect the first time
you literally the first
first time did it perfect didn't even
know what the [ __ ] we had looked what we
had to do
it's so broad so we hit it from the back
falls
is that fire move man if you get by that
fire
all right here we go
oh wow
literally spawn killed the moment
you got him
i got him
all right let's let's go where king is
oh my god i can't
just restart
yeah we gotta die cuz i i don't got no
you don't have one either no no no
remember you died already oh yeah
man this is the this is the barn i
couldn't stand and and forsaken too the
one with the fire lantern the dude
downstairs in the basement
yeah like
they definitely
knew what they were doing man they all
paid for it since it was my fault
okay going in the back
well he's following me
he's on as soon as we kill him
he's down
rip over here in the back
run run run run
you chasing me
i got him on the ropes
all right get it all right let's go
king's first kings first
right behind you watch it
if you're gonna throw a shooter rocket
call it
all right go straight to the left
straight to the left okay
grenade
roof back here
the shield is broken
he down
all right left again
rotate
we're native
riff in the back oh somebody walked in
front of me that was me that's all right
we should have said you were shooting
rockets
yeah
don't worry about it
all right
rip on the floor
breaking crystal have no heavy
i have something he's doing here
where'd he go
[Music]
oh my god i couldn't put it down damn it
i can't
don't worry about me
i can't pick you up
i got him you got him
oh jeez where is he nah he had me
there's nothing i could do
nothing i could do it's fine we got you
i can get him
he hit me into a wall
man this [ __ ] is ridiculous
we got the pattern to him we got the
rhythm
don't
don't no problem
i'm about to switch stuff up
i might not do as much damage as you
guys but i need to help
get
i'm a rock i would rather do something a
little bit more offensive with my super
to clear out rooms i'm gonna rock the
door rather
you want to do the divinity hold on a
second
i'll be able to put it
i'll be able to lock them on this stuff
okay
went down a little bit
what about the whatchamacallit um
the grenades um
that's the divinity right
no the divinity is uh you guys do 30
more damage
okay yeah what's what's the other one
with those grenades that you throw on i
mean well the yellow horn is doing a lot
of damage anyway but
what what's the um
what is it called is
exotic power
now is it tomorrow
all right let's try with this load up
first
anarchy oh yeah i don't have the uh well
let's try this divinity because i
haven't filmed
i have a feeling we'll be doing 30 more
damage
we'll be able to take him down quicker
because i'll shoot you well see what i
was thinking with the anarchy is the
fact that we don't have to worry about
blowing ourselves up plus it'll kill any
ads that's on the outside
but we can trust
foreign
because i'll use the divinity on
uh smaller stuff
oh and when you pull it is 13.50
because i think that anarchy just you
know clears up ads all around too
ready
yeah i'm almost ready
all right
galahon last shot for you buddy you too
dangerous for your own damn good in
these close quarters
i'll use divinity on
the the things in each room and him
himself
all right all right
all right i'm going left
all right let's go
oh yeah we gotta take out the boss
little guy first
shooting
i think he needs to go back to divinity
i think he needs to go back i mean go
back to uh galahorn because we are not
doing enough damage quick enough
what he was using he wasn't using
anarchy yet
dawg was i just put it on
oh
i i didn't see a lot of like
like rockets shooting like usually we
could oh no no no i i just
we shot it and took it down well um
just then
all right well let's let's try it again
i'm gonna go left
all right
all right be careful i'm coming with the
divinity
where is it right there
[Music]
he's running
running after me
he's about to be emil
he's about to be a meal he's a meal go
in the room the uh kings go to where i'm
at
all right going away
oh he almost got me boy
not today
oh come on man
the glaive is good but the glaze is bad
rock it out
let's go
[ __ ] right now
damn it dude that fire man by the time
you see it it's too late
oh
i got you
i wasn't expecting that
don't stay too close
after you forte
did you call me already
his little mini him is worse than him
just trying to take her be careful
where is it
get out of there
all right
follow me
yep over here
what the hell
all right to the left
watch the little dudes on the floor
oh i got some heavy
to the left
jump over
right
all right all right let's do it again
all right go right go right go right
start clearing the ads a little bit
don't worry get the ass first
i'm gonna turn the lights on
i think he's behind us
yep he's behind y'all
right king russia yes sir
mr fire
so what i'm calling out there shooting
sparks
all right keep going keep going keep
going
coming up behind us
almost got my super
i got my silver
he's taylor
kill this [ __ ] i mean this guy
thank god
that was no barrett
but it felt oh
[Music]
okay
i need a [ __ ] talk for all the stuff
that i got we stand before a being with
a thousand nations
it whispers one
the witness
remember it
remember that name
did anybody else hear that
sounded like sabathur who's the witness
no clue
i've never heard that name before hey
that's exciting though right a lead
what's most exciting is that you were
telling the truth
trust her and then
yeah
cautious optimism
don't trust that dude for [ __ ] but let's
not forget
remains at large well hopefully not for
long if we have anything to say about it
i just want to expose sabbath yeah stop
whatever game she's playing you can be
she is
in the meantime what should we do with
zaghira
but i have a theory
bring her back to me as soon as you can
oh that was so and good work
all of you
i was sweat my hands are sweaty
that was some work right there boy
that's only chapter two
they earned their money though
give me a goddamn crypt
go to the
dear tower that was rough
how many hours we was playing at it
so far
probably around four hours
and only up to chapter two
this is giving me what you are calling
vibes then the illusions near sabathun's
fortress giving me um
a brother vibes all linked by the same
energy
the same dark energy
which you can interact with it's been
useful so far
i just don't like how little we know
about it
i bet ipora will have some theories
about all this oh this is the open world
over there
yeah
we could probably just go to the tower
yeah
yeah i know right
now i got space oh look at how mars
looking different with a little
different little stuff going on
let's have a doom space
boy
i'm asleep like baby
and i know a lot of dudes is gonna be
rushing cuz i gotta finish the story
because i wanna be the first one to run
my mouth
i gotta
help me as long as i have all three done
by the end of the week that's all i care
about i got one guy
oh man
well
well i just want to beat it on
this character on this legendary the
oh my gosh man
if you see all the stuff that i got in
here man this is disgusting
you gotta work tomorrow game or tonight
i work every night
not enough space what is this show
the cosmic crowd
cosmographing
show
i will see y'all if y'all long late
you'll be back on later you often think
i'll probably be off in a minute right
after this
all right look um if i see y'all on the
night out back in we could just i'll see
you tonight
[Laughter]
catch you in a minute
brother oh
rebuild the grand overture catalyst by
defeating the cabal
what time is it you got the question
it's a 19 p.m at the moment
what the hell did he just give me
let's get started
it's the catalyst for
and
um
just got this wild ass gun just now
weapon level
weapon level 2.
you got that yet
no i wasn't using um
the uh the enigma well i'm already
weapon level two
no i got some typhoon gl55
hey let's go to the
okay
i'm going now is that cool
there you go
92
93 79
98 91 sixty
oh my gosh man it's
that was
that's probably the that was harder than
any knife i've done in a long time
yeah it's pretty good i mean they're
scaling it properly
can't say this is not scale properly
oh new weapons
sweet sorrow
come to pass
likely suspect
deliverance
new glaives oh there's a
there's
exotic lights here now
exotic glaze
i'm looking at the uh
the table
oh
i'm coming
is is something on this wall over here
first
and grab that up
one of these um
clays you have to have a hunter to get
all right so the mission over here
shaping extract
what
whoa look at those exotic glaze
hunter class titan class
pattern has not been unlocked yet
so each one has a different class
named it
wow
that's a soccer move
you get that sub machine gun catalyst
you got to get that out right there
right
it would be nice if they can actually
put
weapons
oh be nice if they put retrace in there
maybe i just a quick
to complete the objective for
residential
deep sight weapon i don't know what that
is you have a gun called deep side
weapon
no
i'm gonna go
i wonder why my my clothes my boots
still keep glossing over like that
finding seghira
brings up a lot of old rules
when you picked up her shell you were
able to access something
psychic fingerprint
i believe the relic awoke a new ability
within you
one that reveals what lies beneath the
surface
one
rooted in darkness
something tells me this witness
sabathune mentioned is directly tied to
her theft of the light
we need to hear more of that fingerprint
which means you need to strengthen that
ability
we've learned from the pyramid on europa
before
head there
heiress will guide you
if my instincts are correct
this ability could be just what we need
to solve this case
to solve this case
this
oh that's cool like this weapons pattern
could be extracted so if you do stuff
with that weapon you can extract it
and create new ones
yeah that's why you have to um
the the tuning process for these shifts
it's crazy
my kids
all right you guys i appreciate everyone
for coming through man we've been
streaming for about four hours and all
right now it's like three hours and 30
minutes but we strain for a little bit
before i restarted the stream
uh you guys have a good day man uh like
i said we're going to be streaming
um
we're going to be streaming the raid
obviously king won't be part of he don't
do day one raids
but we're gonna be there
and
it's hard to tell how that's gonna work
for those of you that haven't
watched a rave from us
that is not pg i'm sorry come in there
your own your own uh
your own risk but we'll be announcing
that adam
at the uh at the podcast this sunday too
i appreciate everyone for coming through
man 3 hours and 30 minutes